And now a special look at marvel studios
original series loki maybe loki wants to
mix it up is that possible you can change hi this
variant is insubordinate stubborn unpredictable
he's doing great you need the god of
mischief but he's really arrogant i am loki
and i am burdened with glorious purpose
unbelievable wherever you go it's just
death destruction the literal ends of worlds
I know?
I know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the circus
and i see the clowns are playing
their parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you sound
super smart i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
we protect the proper flow of time you
picked up the tesseract breaking reality
i want you to help us fix it
Why me? I need your unique Loki
perspective do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this loki variant
luckily he believes in himself
enough for the both of us
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times why never do it again
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new loki trailer video big surprise they
dropped a new loki trailer in addition to all
the big marvel phase 4 movie trailers yesterday
there's a whole bunch of new easter eggs we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel of course i'll be doing all the episode
videos for this so be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos we'll also do that disney plus
giveaway for memberships all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the loki series in the comments
i love the way loki rolls into this trailer
though like owen wilson says everywhere you
go destruction the death of worlds and loki just
shrugs like yeah exactly so even though all this
new trailer footage is all about tom hiddleston's
new version of loki it's mostly through gugu
mbatha-raw's character ravonna renslayer she's
actually a really big deal in the marvel lore
with some huge connections to king the conqueror
that i'll talk about in a second because obviously
we're going to get a version of him during ant-man
3 quantum mania in a lot of this being framed
through owen wilson's character talking to her
about loki playing the mobius character obviously
his character's name a big reference to time
because of the way that they're playing on all
the conventions of time travel during the series
they're taking a very doctor who and hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy's sense of humor to the series
with the way they play on a lot of these time
travel tropes so if you really like the craziness
of wandavision and you felt like falcon and winter
soldier was a little too regular like a little to
stock in trade i feel like loki is really going
to crank up the dials on the craziness and it
sounds like they had a much clearer idea of what
they wanted the series to be when they plotted
this out and that's one of the reasons why it's
getting a season 2. if you didn't see the good
news either they've already renewed it for season
2 tom hiddleston will be coming back so it'll be
one of those marvel disney plus series that does
get multiple seasons it's just in between season
1 and season 2 he'll cross over to thor 4 love
and thunder but the whole thing here is that you
have judge ren slayer presiding over loki's trial
after they drag him in for destroying the timeline
when he stole the tesseract the space stone from
the main mcu timeline in avengers end game then
they show you the series of the ever increasing
branching timelines from the main timeline that
just goes on forever into the future i'll explain
the time variance authority and the time keepers
in a second but where they are here this whole
city that you see which looks amazing but the time
keepers themselves the statues that you see here
these big statues are beings that exist at the
end of the timeline like the very end of time
at the end of the universe like literally the end
of everything their technology their science is
so advanced that they create the time variance
authority to sort of police the timeline and
make sure to keep its integrity so you don't have
characters like king the conqueror running around
messing with things to their own will that's
exactly what the loki character just did like he
messed with the timeline created all these branch
timelines so now the time variance authority
kind of like the time cops step in to clean up
these alternate timelines and close them down
in ren slayer here just at least initially doesn't
think that this version of loki is anything
special and will just cause them more trouble than
he's worth while mobius owen wilson's characters
trying to advocate for him like he might surprise
us he might change which is a clever reference
to the redeemed loki from avengers infinity war
who sacrificed himself before thanos killed him
the cool thing that you may not have realized in
this is because they sort of exist this pocket
dimension where they are is at the end of
time they witnessed the original timeline
where he redeemed himself thanos assembled
the infinity gauntlet snapped everyone
then the events of avengers end game the blip
happened they've already been able to witness
everything that's ever going to happen in this
timeline which is how they know when it's changed
in a bad way that they need to step in and fix
like how would you be able to fix something if you
didn't know what it was supposed to be originally
but owen wilson's character mobius knows that this
version of loki had he not stolen the tesseract
would have eventually become the redeemed version
of loki just given a couple more years so just to
explain the stakes of the series when they pick up
like the thing that's hanging over loki said they
released this new plot synopsis and a log line
for the series which basically says this new loki
has to help close down all the alternate branching
timelines in realities with the other versions
of loki that he inadvertently created through
his actions or he faces deletion from the timeline
like if he doesn't play along with them the time
variance authority will make it like he never
existed they'll just go back in time to the exact
point where he was about to take the tesseract
and kill him preventing him from creating all
these branching timelines in the first place which
might seem hardcore but it would be the simplest
solution to the problem just go back and make
it so that he never did any of this stuff and
it does sound like they've done things like that
before but mobius is giving loki a chance to fix
things himself also the twist here the reason why
they want this loki is because there's all these
other alternate loki's that he has to go after in
the branch timelines who are even worse than he is
and i think he's trying to rehabilitate him into
one of their star time cops so to speak like i
said they've already confirmed loki season two
and i think the idea is that through multiple
seasons of the show as loki crosses over between
the future marvel movies eventually he will redeem
himself like the original loki redeemed himself
in avengers infinity war and become a truly good
character with a lot of mischief and classic
loki jokes along the way but while they're
having that conversation they intercut it with
the separate scenes of loki trying to pull a
fast one on rensslayer the other time variance
authority troops trying to escape their facility
and failing miserably added that's the whole joke
of the series because all these people are from
the end of time they're so advanced they have so
much technology that there's no way that he's able
to pull a fast one on them but i have a feeling
they're gonna have a lot of fun with that during
episode one where you initially see him here
right after they capture him and he just spends
a lot of that first episode in the early moments
trying to escape and failing miserably at it it
looks amazing if you've ever read any of the king
war storyline or any classic king the conqueror
stories that featured him in his original time
period during the far future it looks a lot like
this i'll talk more about kang the conqueror and
his connection to the timekeepers in a second but
then you see other footage of loki using his magic
to dry himself off it's not just illusions that he
creates like that like when he changes his form
he uses magic just like scarlet witch or doctor
strange would use magic but then you see a much
longer version of what seems like the pompeii
scene with him just grandstanding while the
people are panicking running around going crazy
while the volcano seems like it's erupting in the
background then it sort of turns into this funny
twist on the iron man jericho scene from way back
in marvel phase one much to owen wilson's chagrin
like he can't believe what's going on here this
might just be from early on when he's giving loki
the tutorial and what it is that they do at the
time variance authority just taking him around
to different places in time explaining how they
try to maintain the integrity of the timeline by
gardening and plucking out bad actors eliminating
bad branch timelines i think the idea is that in
the loki series because he used an infinity stone
it created way more branch timelines like in a
way worse way than you would normally see with
someone messing with the timeline like when he's
in this processing queue here you see another
person anybody who's being processed by them is
somebody who has tried to mess with the timeline
i love the idea too in this waiting room you see a
scroll standing nearby you just have to imagine
this is the marvel universe so you'd have many
different characters from other series crossing
over into this many different types of aliens
then i love this other scene with the reference to
the first avengers movie in that scene where he's
just used the tesseract to escape the avengers
tower and avengers end game and he winds up
landing in what seems like the gobi desert on the
opposite side of the planet he wakes up to the
faces of those people who are just confused about
what's going on and gives them the exact same
speech that he gave at the beginning of the first
avengers movie when he stepped through the portal
i am loki and i am burdened with glorious purpose
the funny thing about that you get to remember
when this is happening in the timeline he just
did that because this is right after the end
of the first avengers movie so he basically said
the exact same thing just a little while ago
also the owen wilson joke about everywhere he goes
there's death destruction of worlds is a clever
reference to the destruction of asgard during thor
ragnarok which technically has not happened yet in
this loki's timeline remember owen wilson has seen
the entirety of the original mcu timeline so he
saw the events of thor ragnarok avengers infinity
war avengers end game but just to talk about kang
the conqueror connections and easter eggs the big
connection to kang the conqueror during the loki
series or at least one of the big connections is
that gugu mbatha-raw's character ravonna renslayer
is actually kang's long time love interest in
the comics they didn't start out that way he
pursued her and she didn't want to have anything
to do with him but eventually he won her over
we know that they cast jonathan majors as their
king the conqueror of the mcu for ant-man 3
in the wasp quantomania they finally gave us a
date for that it's coming out february 2023 so
they'll be filming that movie pretty soon i'm not
expecting to see a ton of king the conqueror cameo
scenes during the loki series like if we're
talking about wandavision in our experience
during falcon and winter soldier sort of tune your
expectations accordingly i do think we're gonna
get a lot of easter eggs and references that'll
help set up kang and explain where he comes from
world build so that when we actually get to
ant-man 3 and you see him it all makes sense and
i love the idea that kang himself was originally
part of the time variance authority like maybe
he's a former time keeper himself or one of the
former judges like rent slayer but kang's deeper
connection to the time keepers these giant statues
that you see those are representations of the time
keepers themselves these beings that exist at the
end of all time in space kang was born in the far
distant future many thousands of years in the
future after they'd learned to manipulate time
and he sort of becomes this warrior across
many different timelines and multiple realities
eventually he becomes very embittered when he
loses his son in many different timelines and
his love interests ravana renslayer many different
alternate versions of her wind up dying eventually
the timekeepers recognize what an asset he could
be for them and they try to recruit him to be a
force for good in exchange for that they offer him
immortality so he winds up accepting their offer
and through that becomes the immortus character
who sort of exists in this other alternate limbo
dimension so maybe we'll see a version of that
play out in the mcu eventually like you have king
the conqueror the regular version of him who's
just hopping around in different timelines being
a villain then throughout his story loki's style
you see many alternate versions of him popping
up in the timeline i know a lot of you are also
asking which other characters from the thor movies
are going to cross over onto the loki series and
what's going on with loki or this version of loki
crossing over into thor 4 love and thunder we do
know that loki references thor and heimdall during
the trailer during that db cooper scene like he
says brother heimdall i hope you're ready as the
bifrost catches them after he jumps out of the
plane we see many versions of loki and alternate
versions of asgard so i do think that it's a
safe bet that we will see at least a couple of
the bigger thor characters from the movies showing
up on the series and cameos all the marvel disney
plus series are meant to set up movies so it
sounds like the loki series will also help set up
some of the events of thor 4 love and thunder then
the events of loki season 2 whatever that plot's
going to be will take place after the movie but if
there are any other big easter eggs that i haven't
already covered in my videos that you saw in the
trailer here just write them below in the comments
and let me know what other bonus videos you want
me to do for the loki series before we get episode
one there will be a bunch more trailers between
now and then too i'm still working on a couple
of the trailer videos from yesterday my next one
will be for that new shang chi trailer footage so
that should post either later today or tomorrow
everyone click here for that real big marvel
phase 4 trailer in that brand new eternals
trailer and click here for my other shang chi
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!